hey what's going on everybody sorry if
my microphone sounds a little extra
shitty today I'm actually recording this
at work on my phone I'm actually on my
lunch break right now that way I can get
these new spoilers out to you guys as
soon as possible because I have a few
new spoiler photos for you guys today
and one of these photos is actually
another clue as to what is actually
going to take place in one of next
season's episodes now I'm assuming if
you guys are watching this spoiler video
then you are probably aware of the plot
leaked and if not the plot leaked
basically states that season seven
episode six is going to feature a wide
variety of characters that go on a
mission together north of the wall
apparently Jon Snow tormund Giantsbane
Gendry Jorah Mormont the hound Thoris of
Mir and beric Dondarrion are set to go
on a dangerous mission together north of
the wall and they're planning to go
behind enemy lines to capture a white to
take south to show all the Lords of
Westeros that there is in fact a threat
beyond the wall that needs their
undivided attention immediately and if
all you guys have been up-to-date with
all the spoiler videos that I have
released then you already know that
pretty much everything about this leaked
scene has been confirmed through photos
and reports the leak said that Jon and
this team is going to get surrounded on
a frozen lake by hundreds if not
thousands of whites and spoiler photos
have shown us that they have built a set
with massive green screens on a man-made
frozen lake which is exactly what it
said plus a report also came out about
over a month ago that said that they
already cast over 300 people that
they're going to use as whites and then
they're gonna add a lot more with CGI
and the lake also said that John would
be with several characters that he has
never interacted with before on the show
which were very specific characters and
all those characters have arrived and
been spotted together several times in
the leak also said that John's gonna be
nearly killed but this time his Uncle
Benjen is gonna show up just in time and
he's gonna sacrifice himself that way he
can save Jon and the actor that portrays
Benjen Stark has already been seen with
this odd grouping of character several
times in and around the set in most
recent spoilers have pretty much taken
all doubt out of my mind with
the information it's very hard for me to
say that any of this is fake the Game of
Thrones production team have moved the
cast and crew to Iceland well they're
gonna be filming for the next couple of
weeks
and this isn't the first time the game
of Thrones has filmed here they love to
use Iceland's icy and treacherous
looking landscapes that are perfect for
scenes they want to shoot north of the
wall which is exactly what they're going
to be doing here right now anytime Game
of Thrones is filming in Iceland you can
bet their ass they're gonna be doing
scenes north of the wall which makes
perfect sense for these characters to be
here considering the leak said that this
is going to happen and everything else
leading up to this point has been more
or less confirmed with all the photos
and reports that we have gotten over the
past couple of weeks and months Jon Snow
Jorah
Thoros and ginjury have already been
spotted in Iceland a couple times as
they prepare for their scenes so that
just leaves a few other characters left
to be seen to completely confirm this
part of the leak for me which leads me
to today's spoilers as filming continues
in Iceland today a couple more photos
and reports have came out about what is
actually going to take place and who's
going to be there and as you can see in
this photo sir Davos Seaworth has
arrived in Iceland and he has been seen
hanging out with Gendry but what does
this actually mean does this really mean
that Davos is going to go north of the
wall with Gendry and John and the rest
of the guys not exactly if you remember
from some of my previous spoiler videos
the reports have stated that Davos is
going to travel with them from
Dragonstone which is pretty obvious from
most of the photos because you can see
Davos with John and Gendry and Jorah
heading north but those reports have
said that Davos is not going to go north
of the wall he's basically gonna stay at
the castle on the wall which is
eastwatch-by-the-sea which is a seaside
castle the Nights Watch and if you check
out these other new spoiler photos you
can see that the crew has set up on the
beach and you can actually see that
there are two boats on the beach I'm
assuming that Davos and Gentry are gonna
have some scenes together next season
probably with just the two of them as
well considering they were hanging out
together probably right after shooting
without any other characters I think
it's safe to say by now that Gendry and
Davos have a bear
nice relationship together in the show
considering Davos did save his life
back when Melisandre wanted to sacrifice
him for Stannis
but that's when Davos snuck him out of
Dragonstone and set him on his way and
that's one Gendry for the next couple of
years joined the Westeros Olympic rowing
team but the plot leaked says that Jon's
gonna arrive at eastwatch-by-the-sea and
that's apparently when torment is
already there and he has a Brotherhood
without banners member locked up in the
jail the Brotherhood are supposedly on a
mission from the Lord of Light to fight
the White Walkers which does lineup from
where they left off at the end of season
six if you remember in one of the last
episodes the Brotherhood actually told
the hound that they were heading north
to fight a greater evil which does sound
like the perfect guys that John's gonna
need to go on a mission like this
considering they're already motivated to
do this but why would torment already be
there before John I'm thinking John way
to sent him to the wall while he was at
Dragonstone or possibly when John was
getting ready to leave Dragonstone he
could have sent a raven to Winterfell
telling torment to meet him there and
that's when torment could encounter the
Brotherhood without banners members but
I can't figure out what torment would
have one of these guys locked up in a
jail cell I can really only take a guess
and assume that one of the Brotherhood
members was possibly trying to steal
some food or some weapons or horses or
something like that to take with them
north of the wall for their mission for
the Lord of Light or possibly they could
have tried to cross the wall without
permission and they could have gotten a
fight with one of the Nights Watch
members and that's how one of them could
ended up in jail I'm really not too sure
so if you guys have a good answer for
that please comment below because I'd
love to know and be able to piece this
together a little bit more accurately
and you guys always give me some great
answers but I think when John gets there
and he hears that these guys also wanted
to go north of the wall to fight the
White Walkers I think John's probably
gonna offer the guy a deal that's in
jail assuming that there is a man locked
up in the cells which I'm gonna assume
is accurate because everything else in
this leak for this episode has been
accurate I think John's probably going
to grant him his freedom as long as he
helps him on this mission to capture a
wipe but I think there's something
interesting
here that I should mention if you notice
in the leak it mentions Thoris of Mir
and beric Dondarrion by their name but
when it mentions that one of them is in
jail it doesn't give the person's name
it just says a Brotherhood without
banners member so I'm thinking the
person that's in jail must be a
different member of the Brotherhood
because I think if it was stores so
barek it would actually say their name
so I think this could be one of the guys
that goes north of the wall with them on
his mission it might even be their
Archer which would be a nice addition to
their team so do you guys think that
this Brotherhood without banners member
could be one of the extra unknown
characters that go north of the wall or
could the reports be wrong about Davos
could Davos actually go with these guys
north of the wall instead of just
sitting there waiting for them at
eastwatch-by-the-sea if you watch my
last spoiler video you would know that
there is at least one or maybe even two
extra characters that are going to go on
his mission north of the wall because
the leak originally stated that only
seven people in total are going to go
but in the photos you can actually see
that there are at least eight or nine
people traveling together that are
wearing the exact same type of clothing
in search of a white now that Davos has
arrived in Iceland could he end up going
with John and company I think this is
very interesting or could the
Brotherhood without banners member that
torment has locked up in jail be the
extra character that goes I think either
one's pretty likely and that's what I'm
leaning towards possibly another
Brotherhood one member or maybe Poorman
has another wildling with them to help
them navigate throughout the treacherous
landscapes north of the wall it's still
a little too early for me to tell who
that other character may be but what
Davos in town I think he could end up
going with these guys but the t-shirt
that I'm giving away for whoever guessed
the right person first is still going to
be up for grabs
until I see Davos actually what these
guys or at least wearing the same type
of coat that these guys were wearing I
can't guarantee that he's going to go
north of the wall with John to get away
so stay tuned because there's gonna
still be filming in Iceland they're
probably gonna be there for at least
another week or so and I guarantee you
we're gonna get a lot more spoilers
still to come and also I have two more
breakdown video
is about the plot lake but I need to do
for you guys and after I get those out
to you that's what I'm gonna do that
Gendry video that I've been talking
about I'm gonna explain exactly what the
hell ginjury has been up to and what
he's about to do in the future it's not
only gonna be a season seven prediction
I'm gonna explain ginjuries entire
purpose for coming back in his endgame
what's I'm very anxious to dive into so
stay tuned for that my friends but
before I go guys I want to recommend a
few Game of Thrones channels what some
of you who are very hardcore Game of
Thrones fans are probably already aware
of but if not check out Don Willy and
cows [ __ ] chickens channel Don Willy
has been an amazing part of this
community for at least for me he has
supported me ever since I first started
making videos he was one of my first
subscribers actually I'm not even sure
how he came across to any of my stuff
but he has welcomed me into this
community with open arms and has done
nothing but shown love ever since so I
can't recommend his channel enough he
was one of the channels that I actually
watched personally before I ever made
any videos of my own so definitely check
him out he's one of the godfathers of
this whole game of Thrones YouTube
videos community in cows [ __ ]
chickens me and him I've been talking
recently he's a great guy he's shown me
nothing but respect as well and me and
him got some future projects lined up so
stay tuned for that because me Kyle and
Dawn are gonna be doing some live
streams within the next few weeks which
is something I'm gonna start doing more
of to add to this channel now that I got
some new equipment coming I've been
reaching out to other Game of Thrones
channels so we can start doing some
collabs together so go check out those
two channels please get familiar with
those guys if you aren't already because
very soon I'm gonna start putting out
some videos with these guys just to add
a little bit different flavor to this
channel give you guys a little bit
something different a little different
perspectives so I hope you guys are
looking forward to that and I know I can
count on you guys to show them the same
amount of love that you guys have always
shown me I appreciate you guys for that
I love you guys for that but comment
below guys because I want to get your
opinion on this why do you think torment
was already there before John was there
and why do you think torment has
the Brotherhood without banners member
locked up in the jail cell let me know
what you guys think about that and as
always thanks for listening thanks for
to support I will see you guys in the
comments section bye